mais
[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle édition de parlement
hebdo le meilleur de la semaine
politique et parlementaire avec un
décolleté michael jamais bonjour katia
bonjour a tous notre invité pierre
laurent bonjour bonjour secrétaire
nationale du parti communiste sénateur
de paris l'actualité cette semaine le
parlement qui fait sa révolution le
président de l'assemblée a dévoilé les
pistes pour réformer l'assemblée le
sénat doit lui aussi faire ses
propositions le budget 2010 8 votée par
les deux chambres mais pas dans les
mêmes termes
les sénateurs ont détricoté la version
des députés le texte est de retour à
l'assemblée
et puis le dossier alsthom devant la
commission d' enquête lancée à
l'assemblée nationale l'ancien ministre
arnaud montebourg était auditionné à
l'assemblée
mais d'abord l'heure des réformes qui a
sonné à l'assemblée comme au sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'assemblée sept groupes de travail
ont été mises en place pour proposer des
pistes de réforme pour simplifier la
procédure parlementaire donner plus de
moyens de contrôle au législateur ou
encore réduire le nombre de députés et
sénateurs
on voit tout cela avec marion châtain
c'était une promesse de campagne
d'emmanuel macron baissé de 30% le
nombre de députés et de sénateurs
la proposition a fait consensus dans le
groupe de travail nos concitoyens
considèrent que nous avons beaucoup de
trop de représentants alors c'est vrai
que nous avons fait une forme de
benchmark en regardant ce qui se passait
dans les autres pays et la france
aujourd'hui est plutôt dans la
fourchette un petit peu élevé par
rapport aux ratios sur ses représentants
mais si l'on veut garder de l'efficacité
au service de nos circonscriptions
il faut que cela se fasse à moyens
constants si les recommandations du
groupe de travail sont adoptés il n'y
aurait plus que 4 103 députés maximum à
l'assemblée nationale contre 577
aujourd'hui côté sénat le nombre d'élus
passerait de 348 à 244 tout au plus
conséquence les circonscriptions
devraient être redécoupés elles seraient
moins nombreuses et plus grande parmi
les autres mesures phare l'élection
d'environ 20 % de députées au mode de
scrutin proportionnel pour mieux
représenter les petits partis sans
empêcher la constitution de majorités
stables
la limitation du cumul des mandats dans
le temps pas plus de trois mandats
identique et successifs pour tous les
élus enfin l' interdiction dans la
constitution de cumuler les fonctions de
membre du gouvernement avec un mandat
d'exécutif local
la question de l'immunité parlementaire
ne figure pas dans les propositions du
groupe qui n'envisage ni sa réforme ni
sa suppression
voilà pour ce sujet de loris et marion
châtelain pierre laurent
244 sénateurs contre 348 que vous êtes
actuellement est ce que pour vous cette
réduction du nombre de parlementaires
est une réforme démocratique
c'est exactement le contraire c'est une
réforme extrêmement inquiétante pour la
démocratie pour les députés par exemple
aujourd'hui il ya un député pour environ
cent vingt mille habitants on aura un
député pour 230 mille habitants dans une
circonscription alors qu'on nous
explique que ça va permettre le
rapprochement entre les citoyens et les
parlementaires il faut en faire la
démonstration
244 sénateurs ça veut dire qu'on a deux
sénateurs et demie en moyenne par
département il ya déjà des départements
qui n'ont qu'un seul sénateur
comment est ce qu'on va faire la une
répartition rendre les citoyens égaux
devant la représentation parlementaire
en vérité tout ce qui est en train de se
préparer c'est l'abaissement du
parlement
on veut réduire le nombre de
parlementaires réduire ses moyens on
travaille à vis et des analyses pour
renforcer une nouvelle fois la
concentration du pouvoir où nous vivons
déjà centre parce que j'entends parler
de comparaison européenne dans notre
reportage
nous avons le régime est de loin le plus
présidentialiser de toute l'europe y a
aucun pays d'europe qui fonctionne avec
intel une telle concentration des
pouvoirs dans les mains du président
aucun nous sommes le seul à fonctionner
comme ça à regarder
même les britanniques j'ai beaucoup de
choses à dire sur les britanniques et
leur politique actuelle et beaucoup
viennent de voter par exemple au
parlement un pouvoir de contrôle ni
totale sur les décisions concernant les
antilles avoue-t-il au parc emmanuel me
concentre à lui tout seul tous les
pouvoirs aujourd'hui il est qu'il veut
garder tout ça c'est la constitution qui
l'est concentre à l'excès rêve dans là
il veut renforcer cela et il veut
technocrates is et le parlement et au
lieu d'en faire une assemblée souveraine
de représentation du peuple on faire une
espèce d'assemblée technique
consultative remplissez pas bien entendu
dans son discours à versailles
oui très ouvert sur le parlement il
donnait une série de modifications et de
modernisation du parlement oui mais par
exemple ou au sénat en ce moment les
propositions qui ont été votées hier
sauf par un groupe lenôtre et qui vise à
supprimer le débat en séance publique
sur toute une série d'amendements
possibles c'est à dire on est en train
de restreindre le premier envisage même
on envisage même dans ce qui a été voté
hier
ce qui est incroyable
que quand un projet de loi va venir on
débat on puisse soustraire une partie
des articles de ce projet de loi au
débat en séance publique pour l'examiner
vous et dangereux comme il est dangereux
c'est le débat en séance publique
c'est le moment de vérité et de
transparence abri s'est vite aujourd'hui
vous comprenez pour aussi c'est fait non
je ne pense pas que sa loi je pense
qu'il faut au contraire arrêté avec
l'inflation législative et avec
l'accélération du travail législatif
alors c'est ce cri parce que il faut que
nous ayons le temps de discuter avec la
société des projets d'eau
regardez ce qui se passe sur notre dame
des landes quand on va trop vite en
parlera très bien et bien on peut faire
n'importe quoi et c'est vrai de beaucoup
de sujets en l'état s'il ya une
convocation du congrès donc députés et
sénateurs à versailles
vous ne votez pas les réformes qui sont
proposés qui devront passer par une
révision du bien sûr nous ne voterons
pas mais pas seulement ça nous allons au
début du mois de janvier nous exprimer
les deux groupes vont s'exprimer
ensemble celui du de l'assemblée et du
sénat et nous allons engager une
campagne d'explication publique dans le
pays parce que tout ça se fait en
laissant totalement à l'écart on est en
train de changer des choses essentielles
dans la bien démocrate aglaé médication
aucun débat public dans le pays
donc il faut mettre les citoyens dans le
coup et -pour le moment- part à tous qui
veut pour d'abord leur dire la vérité
risque et tenteront de pareilles
s'expliquer sur les conséquences
antidémocratique de ces mesures
et puis construire d'autres propositions
par exemple pourquoi on nous dit 20% de
d'élus à la proportionnelle ça va
permettre de mieux représenter c'est
faux c'est absolument faux avec 20% élus
à la proportionnelle et les noms de
parlementaires il y aura pas plus d'élus
de la france insoumise et du parti
communiste qui en a aujourd'hui et
peut-être de 20 ans peut-être moi donc
en vérité on ment aux français sur ce
qui est en train de se préparer et nous
nous allons mener une campagne de vérité
dans le pays sur ces questions alors
donc le budget examiné et elle vaut
cette semaine par les sénateurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur les scènes sur la taxe d'habitation
les sénateurs ont largement amendé le
projet de budget voté par les députés
voici les détails avec templeraud c'est
la fin d'un marathon parlementaire après
près de trois semaines de débats les
sénateurs ont achevé l'examen de
l'ensemble du budget 2018
aujourd'hui place au vote avec à
l'arrivée de nombreuses modifications
par rapport au texte d'origine retour
d'abord sur les principaux dossiers le
sénat veut la suppression totale de
l'impôt sur la fortune et non une
suppression partielle via la mise en
place d'un impôt sur la fortune
immobilière impôts dont les sénateurs ne
veulent pas
concernant la taxe d'habitation le sénat
n'est pas opposé sur le principe à sa
suppression mais demande un an de
concertation au préalable le sénat
demande la création d'une nouvelle
réserve parlementaire l'ancien ayant été
supprimée cet été cette nouvelle mouture
prévoit 86 millions d'euros de dotations
aux communes de moins de 2000 habitants
enfin le sénat souhaite que le plafond
du quotient familial soit relevé de 200
euros
dans la dernière ligne droite des débats
de nombreux amendements ont été ajoutées
notamment ce lundi certains font
polémique
à commencer par l'augmentation de 40%
des salaires des maires de communes de
plus de 500 mille habitants et des
présidents de collectivités régions et
départements
autre amendement controversé
l'instauration de trois jours de carence
pour les fonctionnaires durant
lesquelles leur arrêt maladie ne
seraient pas rémunérées
il s'agit d'un alignement sur le privé
contrairement à celui de 2010 est le
sénat n'est pas totalement hostile au
budget présenté par le gouvernement pour
2018 ont été rejetées les crédits sur
l'immigration la justice la sécurité
l'agriculture et le travail ont été
adoptées ce sur la défense l'éducation
l'enseignement supérieur l'outre-mer le
sport la santé la solidarité l'écologie
la culture et l'économie
donc je le disais nous a complètement
modifié par rapport à celle de la somme
est en tout cas pour à quelques détails
près
pour vous le budget des manuels makusha
budget voté par les sénateurs à majorité
du même nom mais je crois que il faut
bien voir ce qui est en train de se
passer en vérité sur les fondamentaux
emmanuel macron et la droite sont
d'accord et les modifications du sénat
ne met absolument pas en cause les
fondamentaux du budget qui sont d'un
côté est à une massification des
exonérations de cotisations sociales des
exonérations fiscales le maintien du
service d'ailleurs la droite sénatoriale
a voté le budget sur l'économie et par
contre la droite
on veut encore davantage veut droitiser
encore le budget alors il faut supprimer
l'impôt ce qui reste de l'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune général de la
droite et il en rajoute avec les trois
jeux deuil dans l'autre sens avec les
trois jours de carence pour les
fonctionnaires non les principes
austérité d'un côté austérité sociale et
privilège pour le capital qui est la
philosophie de ce budget est bien s'est
maintenue par la droite et ensuite la
droite en rajoute
mais c'est pas une différence de
philosophie il ya un accord sur les
fonts d'agrandir et de droite et de
gauche
non mais il n'y a rien de gauche et dans
le budget rien de gauche dans le budget
il ya et de droite et de droite c'est
toi là il ya un peu plus de droite
encore après le vote du sénat
alors après le vote du sénat donc après
donc il ya eu un échec de la commission
de conciliation entre députés et
sénateurs donc une nouvelle lecture
actuellement à l'assemblée c'est
l'assemblée qui aura le dernier mot sur
ce premier budget de la législature
c'est normal c'est comme ça c'est la
procédure ça c'est la procédure c'est la
procédure actuelle le bon il faudrait
d'ailleurs des fois ça se produit
breakée dès conciliation dans les
commissions mixtes paritaires là il y en
a pas eu on va probablement revenir à
peu de choses près j'ai voté par
l'assemblée dans ce budget notamment
dans ce cas réexaminé à l'assemblée
nationale ce vendredi
il ya un assouplissement volonté de la
part du premier ministre qui a fait ces
annonces lors de la conférence nationale
des territoires sur la fiscalité locale
est ce que vous voyez ça d'un bon oeil
main tendue vers les collectivités jean
que ça vous l'attendiez donc il n'ya pas
du tout de main tendue sur les
collectivités
au contraire on est la preuve qu'il est
en train d'asphyxier les ressources des
collectivités locales et de les priver
et en particulier les communes et de les
priver de marge de manoeuvre
parce que après la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation les marges de
manoeuvre d'une commune sont quasi
nulles
et comme on fait pression à la baisse
sur les dotations des collectivités
locales
en vérité on est en train d'engager un
mouvement massif de réduction des
services publics
la première fois qu'on ne baisse pas
justement ces dotations c'est la
première fois qu'elles sont bonnes
notamment la dotation globale de
fonctionnement des communes
ces faits divers et on fait le solde de
toutes les mesures qui sont prises de
toutes les mesures qui n'ont pas été
compensés depuis des années les moyens
des collectivités locales allait
discuter avec n'importe quelle mère un
maire d'une petite commune comme un
maire d'une grande ville
il vous fera la démonstration de la
perte très conséquente de moyens des
collectivités locales en quelques années
et maintenant on est arrivé dans une
situation il ya des collectivités
locales qui sont obligés de taper dans
le dur c'est à dire de supprimer des
services publics locaux ou d'abîmer la
qualité de ses services publics locaux
sur des choses très importantes dans la
vie quotidienne des familles donc on
vend du mirage aux gens en leur parlant
par exemple d'augmentation du pouvoir
d'achat avec la baisse de la taxe
d'habitation disent qu'ils vont payer
beaucoup plus cher les services publics
locaux
donc ce qu'on va leur donner d'une main
on va le reprendre de l'autre
la différence c'est que le gouvernement
va dire ah bah adressez-vous à votre
mère c'est à lui de se débrouiller avec
le problème alors qu'en vérité c'est la
tendance est en train de dépêcher de
mener des politiques qui n'est pas bien
que l'état prenne en charge justement 80
pour 80% des foyers prennent en chasse
est un nom mais ce qu'il faudrait c'est
fan d'harry tab réforme la fiscalité
réel normes et oui mais pour le moment
mais y'a rien mais y'a rien qui est
prévu il faudrait reconstruire par
exemple en impôt économique local on a
supprimé la taxe professionnelle est
encore la remplacer par rien du tout il
faudrait repenser une réforme juste
effectivement de la taxe d'habitation
mais là on la supprime en la remplaçant
par ailleurs du tout alors on va parler
d'un autre moment fort qui a lieu à
l'assemblée ce mercredi un ancien
ministre était auditionnée au palais
bourbon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est arnaud montebourg qui est venu
devant la commission d' enquête sur la
politique industrielle française qui a
été créé à l'assemblée il a livré sa
version de la vente de la branche
énergie d'alstom à general electric
c'était en 2014
il déplore le manque de soutien de
l'exécutif de l'époque
céline martel general electric
respecte-t-il ses engagements lorsque le
groupe rachète la branche énergie
d'alstom en 2015 il promet de créer 1000
emplois en france d'ici la fin 2010 8
c'était l'une des conditions pour que le
gouvernement approuve ce rachat à
l'assemblée nationale des députés réunis
en commission denquête questionne les
dirigeants du groupe sur le nombre
actuel de ces embauches nous avons déjà
nous avons réussi à créer au jour à fin
octobre 2010 7 358 emplois nets sur le
territoire
bien loin des 1000 emplois promis un
objectif que jérôme pécresse
le pdg d'une des filiales du groupe ne
peut garantir dans un contexte de marché
très mouvant et un peu difficile pour
moi de me détruire avec certitude sur la
réalité que nous vivons dans un an ce
que je peux vous dire que nous avons
fait une très bonne partie du chemin
un chemin qui s'annonce périlleux le
géant américain a annoncé qu'il allait
supprimer 2000 emplois dans le monde
déjà un plan social menace 345 emploi
d'une usine du groupe à grenoble
une situation inacceptable pour arnaud
montebourg ministre de l'économie de
l'époque
c'est lui qui a négocié ses engagements
avec le pdg jeffrey il est aussi une
belle nous a raconté des menteries quand
il est venu à l'elysée dans mon bureau
à chaque fois que nous avons une
discussion donc les accords qui sont
d'éloignement exécuté doivent être
sanctionnés et l'état a les moyens de le
faire aujourd'hui
il faut juste accepter de se brouiller
avec quelques personnalités de
l'establishment mondiale juge de la
commission denquête se penchera ensuite
sur les conditions du rachat de la
société stx par un groupe italien
elle se donne six mois pour rendre ses
conclusions sur l'état de la politique
industrielle française à l'ordre lors de
cette audition de deux heures trente
arnaud montebourg a accusé emmanuel
macron qui l'a remplacé à l'époque à
bercy d'avoir laissé l'entreprise
américaine
j électrique prendre le contrôle
d'alstom est-ce qu'il a raison quand il
dit ça c'est u2 c'est une évidence
on voit bien la situation dans laquelle
nous nous trouvons et le bradage de ce
fleuron industriel qui alstom continue
et c'est une folie parce que nous sommes
en train d'abandonner notre maîtrise et
de savoir faire industriel dont deux
domaines qui sont au coeur des enjeux
climatiques et énergétiques de demain le
ferroviaire et l'énergie
c'est à dire qu'on a d'un côté un
président de la république qui nous dit
il faut mobiliser la terre entière pour
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique et de l'autre côté les atouts
industriels nécessaires pour pouvoir
être à l'offensive réellement sur sa au
delà des déclarations d'intention
nous sommes en train de les brader et le
pire c'est que nous les bras donc pour
ce qui est de l'énergie un groupe
américain qui va être soumis aux
injonctions de trump qui lui est en
train de faire exactement le contraire
de ce qu'a fait la france peut faire
marche arrière
bien sûr que nous les faire marche
arrière avant nous pouvons rqap italy's
et l'entreprise en utilisant les fonds
publics nous pouvons nous battre en
europe aujourd'hui devraient pour que
l'argent de la banque centrale
européenne
au lieu d'aller nourrir les marchés
financiers et les créanciers et bien
servent à injecter de l'argent dans des
projets industriels nécessaires nous
pouvons utiliser la commande publique
pour obliger à ce que se nouent des
coopération efficace entre le monde
industriel et les grands services
publics qui sont qui ont besoin de ces
années nationalisation notamment sur des
entreprises c'est le voeu de prôner le
maire même s'il ne disait pas comme ça
c'était nationalisée c'est une demande
que vous faites aujourd'hui la
république sur alstom
ils vont construire il faut reconstruire
un outil industriel maîtriser
nationalement on peut discuter discuter
ça peut être nationalisation ça peut
être avec d'autres formes ça peut être
avec un tour de table capitalistique qui
permet la maîtrise industrielle
nationale il ya plusieurs formules
possibles mais il faut d'abord poser le
principe de cela je vous prends un
exemple concret grenoble j'y suis allé à
l'entreprise
il s'agit du secteur de l'hydro et de
l'hydraulique de l'hydroélectrique on
est en train de brader d'un côté la
maîtrise publique
des barrages des grands barrages
hydroélectriques
alors qu'il faut faire exactement
l'inversé pour maîtriser notre politique
du renouvelable à l'avenir et en même
temps on risque de perdre nos savoir
faire industriel et des boîtes ans je
suis allé et fleurs quand je suis allé à
grenoble il y avait là autour de la
table et syndical l'entreprise et les
syndicalistes d'edf qui s'occupe de ces
questions là il faut faire travailler
ces entreprises ensemble et là on est en
train de déréglementer de tout cas c'est
l'internât des fleurons industriels mais
bien sûr on est en train de lâcher
l'énergie mais c'est cdk et le pdg dans
l'audition arts ea a redit que nous
allions largué nos actifs dans l'énergie
au profit de general electric et nous
sommes en train de faire la même chose
dans le ferroviaire au profit de siemens
c'est à dire que nous nous mettons à nu
sur deux secteurs stratégiques pour
conduire au plan industriel la
transition énergétique nécessaire je
voulais une folie vais vous présenter
mais grâce à notre partenaire du figaro
c'est à lui dans une petite seconde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour dimokratia bonjour pierre
laurent on va continuer à parler de
d'énergie et d'écologie puisque manuel
macron présidé mardi le one planet
summit qui était destiné à sensibiliser
les acteurs de la finance autour des
enjeux climatiques sur le sujet du
climat
le pcf a des positions qui sont devenus
un peu iconoclaste à gauche notamment
sur la question du nucléaire
beaucoup de forces politiques de gauche
se sont convertis à la sortie
progressive du nucléaire et vous vous
défendez encore la filière existantes
pourquoi donc nous on caricature
toujours d'autres positions
ça fait des années que ça dure je ne
sais pas pourquoi alors expliquez nous
c'est très simple nous nous pensons
qu'il faut un mix énergétique pour
sortir au plus vite des énergies
carbonées
pour cela il faut faire monter en régime
de manière très importante les énergies
renouvelables ça c'est la position du
parti communiste et parce que nous
croyons effectivement que ça n'est pas
possible de sortir en 10 15 ans du
nucléaire
il faut donc maintenir pendant une
période de transition qui va durer
plusieurs décennies le nucléaire et des
énergies renouvelables et en plus il
faudrait s'occuper du nucléaire c'est à
dire de la sécurisation faudrait mettre
fin à la sous traitance dans nucléaire
il y aurait beaucoup d'autres à l'ucl
est enfermé sa voilà ce qu'est la
position du du parti communiste je
remarque que nicolas hulot avec lequel
je discute comme avec d'autres
considèrent ne considère pas comme une
folie la position qui est la nôtre parce
que la période de transition que nous
nous demandons parce que elle permet
justement la maîtrise de la conduite la
maîtrise publique de la conduisent cette
transition énergétique est une position
les plutôt raisonnable est fixée
initialement soit irréalisable selon
vous c'est celle les objectifs qui
avaient été fixés initialement de la
sortie d'une classe sont irréalisables
non mais il n'y a pas d'objectif qui
était véritablement étudié et datée de
la sortie du nucléaire pour le moment on
a dit on veut réduire la part du
nucléaire dans le mix énergétique
encore faudrait-il pour ça être capable
de faire monter beaucoup plus vite
la filière industrielle du renouvelable
en france il ya semble-t-il des
décisions qui commencent à être prises
notamment en matière solaire
et tant mieux mais il faut le faire tout
ça dans la cohérence dans la mettrons
pas notre sujet c'est celui de notre
dame des landes dont on parle beaucoup
il ya un nouveau rapport qui a été remis
cette semaine vous êtes pour le pcf la
construction de l'aéroport
on a on a eu une discussion très
partagés nous aussi sur ces questions
moi j'ai beaucoup envie de lire je n'ai
pas fait encore donc je vais pas vous
raconter n'importe quoi j'ai beaucoup
envie de lire le rapport qui me paraît
extrêmement intéressant là le pas le
rapport qui a été fait par les élèves et
ils apportent visiblement des éléments
nouveaux de chiffrage sur les deux
visiblement si je comprends bien ce que
j'ai lu les deux solutions se valent
enfin elles ont des avantages et des
inconvénients l'une locale et s'est
toujours défendu la construction les les
colonisent de loire atlantique ont
toujours ont été favorables au projet à
des conditions qui n'ont pas toujours
été réunis par ailleurs et donc en
posant des conditions qui n'ont pas
toujours été écoutés et puis d'autres
communisme et devant la région hostile à
ça ya toujours eu un débat très partagés
chez nous sur cette question moi je
crois que le rapport à l'air extrêmement
sérieux j'espère qu'on n'en tiendra
compte personnellement sur la za des
symboles évacuer la grappa le trio 10 le
rat par la très connue
l'évacuation la zad de de toute façon
dans une solution comme dans l'autre on
voit pas l'intérêt de maintenir
l'évacuation le l'occupation de la zad
il faut ce qui est important le problème
c'est pas c'est pas la zad le poste qui
est important c'est que c'est quelle est
la solution qu'on va trouver à la fois
d'autant l'intérêt du pays de la région
et une solution qui soit accepté par le
maximum de monde c'est cela qu'il faut
essayer de construire alors je vais vous
citer une fois n'est pas coutume phrase
de jean luc mélenchon cette semaine dans
les échos il parlait mais rien et au
messie
s'arrêter dessus était déçu il dit donc
front national et nationalistes ram pour
moi d'une certaine manière en
contribuant à la construction d'un champ
culturel où nos mots d'ordre sont en
train de devenir dominants est ce qu'il
est en train de construire des ponts
idéologique avec le front national sur
la question européenne
est ce que ça vous laisse j'ai lu cette
phrase qui est extrait d'une interview
qu'il a accordée aux échos sur la
question européenne
elle confirme avec d'autres phrases de
cette interview un désaccord que nous
avons non pas sur la critique du
caractère ultra libéral de l'union
européenne actuelle nous partageons ce
diagnostic mais sur la manière dont nous
allons sortir de la situation actuelle
et moi je crois que nous aurions tort
d'abandonner le terrain pour sortir de
cette situation de la construction de
passerelles avec les forces de gauche
dans toute l'europe
en menant le débat sur le terrain
européen parce que c'est à l'échelle
européenne qu'il faut créer et
rapprocherait de la cassure dernière
création très rapidement on parle de
france télévisions delphine ernotte a
été la cible d'une motion de défiance
votée très largement qui dénonce un
sacré un service public sacrifiés est ce
que le c'est la faute de l'état du
désengagement l'état ou bien eu de
madame ernotte j'ai posé sur écrit très
clair au gouvernement hier aussi une
question orale par nos questions
d'actualité sur ça on amie delphine
ernotte dans une situation impossible le
gouvernement a pris une décision
scandaleuse de réduction de 50 millions
du budget de france télévisions au mois
de septembre et a dit à l'ats pdg dans
les trois mois qui viennent vous devez
faire ces économies
donc on a provoqué le gouvernement a
provoqué une nouvelle crise au sein de
france télévisions et france dans la vue
bien sûr et je pense et j'ai alerté hier
dans ma question il faut bien en avoir
conscience le gouvernement est en train
de vouloir porter des cours est
extrêmement grave à tout le service
public audiovisuel et les déclarations
du président de la république dans une
réunion soit disant à huit clos à
l'elysée disant que le service public
était là ondes
il le montre eh bien ce sera le mot de
la fin merci pierre change avant était
l'invité de parlement hebdo on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine comme ça
pas d'atouts
[Musique]